[Musique]
alain fravette est le plus ancien
employé du collège Bourbon à Saint-Denis
depuis 38 ans cet agent polyvalent
entretient les locaux et les espaces
verts de l'établissement veille à l'état
des véhicules de service il s'occupe
aussi du bon fonctionnement de la
reprographie à 2 ans de la retraite il
n'a jamais envisagé de changer de poste
je suis arrivé ici le 2 novembre
78 déjà mon travail je l'aime mon
travail j'essaie de donner le le
maximum que je peux et je me plais la
preuve en est je je suis toujours là
aujourd'hui et puis j'ai pu voir aussi
toutes
l'évolution matérielle
surtout depuis cette dage qu'aujourd'hui
bon on n pas cessé d'améliorer les
conditions de travail quoi alors le
matin j'arrive à 6h alors je prence en
rux avec tout ce qu'il y a dessus pour
le nettoyage les produits pour la table
adaptés pour la table et puis on
commence
comm chaque jour alin débute sa journée
par le nettoyage des locaux au total ce
sont 13 salles de classe qu'il doit
nettoyer quotidiennement alors là ça
consiste à nettoyer l'état Branger des
chaises essuer le tableau vider la
poubelle et remettre en état quand Mo
l'enseignant arrive élèv arrivent les
salles sont on est prêt la salle soit
prête à accueillir les élèves dans des
bonnes conditions malgré ces années
d'expérience et l'attachement qu'il
porte à son métier alain est confronté à
quelques désagréments qui lui résistent
encore les swingom c'est ça le gros
souci les swingum les écritures sur les
sur les tables mais comme on a on a des
produits adapté pour ça et bon bah mais
quand même des fois c'est on perd on
perd du temps pour enlever tout ça
dans la salle des professeurs les
photocopieuses sont des outils
indispensable manque de papier ou encore
bourrage c'est Alain qui veille au bon
fonctionnement de ses appareils un gain
de temps pour les enseignants al
j'arrive le matin je vérifie les s'il
reste du
papier pour
rechanger on a de de photocopieur
de toujours c'est le bon fonctionnement
de ces appareils que moi qui été bien
dessus pour tout incident pourquoi pour
le pour remettre en état de marche aussi
quand quand il manque du
papier il y a personne d'autre qui
intervient quand Alain prendra sa
retraite dans 2 ans cela fera 40 ans
passer au collège Bourbon 40 années où
il aura contribué à ce que élèv
enseignant puissent travailler dans les
meilleures
[Musique]
conditions